my boyfriend's lactose-intolerant and it
was like an issue for a while but we
worked through it and we're stronger
because of it that sounds messy
okay what's up you guys so earlier this
week Burger King released their Lucky
Charms milkshake so inevitably it was
time for me to go up town milkshakes and
make my quarters tried that and here we
are
[Music]
I love milkshakes
I love milkshakes so much I could have a
milkshake every day I'm also super
lactose intolerant I like milkshakes
sure I'm a huge milkshake fan I love
Burger King I love fast food burgers I
like food that's not good for me
I love Burger King I haven't eaten
Burger King since I was like 14 the
ambiance this smell the chicken fries I
like Lucky Charms I'm in it more for the
marshmallows yeah yeah pregnant I get
cravings lucky terms is in that category
did you know that it was a lucky charm
smokey
No if this were not tasty I would be
full bored if it's soggy cereal and a
milkshake
tap now I feel like it's gonna be a lot
of sugar I see it can we have it
we are excited let's just do this let's
do it it looks like funfetti milkshake
looks like a party in a cup but you can
see like a nice little rainbow around
the top I thought there would be more
color that smells like the frosting you
got out of the can you know they should
have topped it with marshmallows yeah
it's so thick it's like if you put heavy
cream in your cereal every morning Wow
I'm not seeing four-leaf clovers
rainbows balloons pots of gold whoa this
thing is super good you know how much
sugar is in this I don't think I want to
know how much sugar is in this because I
want to enjoy it and not know they
should do cinnamon toast crunch honestly
cuz that's the best cereal send me toast
crunch
I would actually spend my own money on
this but thank you BuzzFeed I would say
definitely go try this share it with a
friend so you stop yourself from
drinking the whole thing if there was a
Burger King near where I lived I'd get
this
I'm really into this I support this I
didn't think I would I was a skeptic but
I'm into it okay so the reviews are in
some people like the last some people
didn't like it as much it's really sweet
tastes like a milkshake tastes like a
marshmallow if you've had the Burger
King went to Charm School shake let us
know in the comments below how you liked
it and that's about all I have to say
about that
[Music]
[Music]